huge parks and recreation fan and I have
a very embarrassing confession I did I
told him backstage but in 2011 I tweeted
I didn't just tweet I begged to be on
parks just so I could be in the scene
with Ron Swanson because I was obsessed
here's the thing I even own that I was a
horrible actor I'm a horrible actor but
I but I I have a lot of spirit and I
could have played a bad actor I didn't
get a call it's fine it's fine Amy it's
fine you know but if I if we could turn
back time with share and and you gave
what do you think I could have played
like maybe maybe like a stage 5 cleaner
well it's a huge compliment first of all
I'm very grateful that you wanted to be
on the show dude it's great it was so
great there's so many great actors on it
well I was I was grateful to get to get
to go to work every day and I think I
think they were you know great comedy
writers you know they look at me and
they say we can make people laugh with
this give that give that guy a coffee
cup oh yeah here we go give him a phone
on his belt all right you know what the
physical comedy is Sookie is so great
but I think they would look at you and
they take your strengths and they would
say okay let's let's cast Kelly is a
very enthusiastic wildly enthusiastic
like hurricane of positivity yes and I
think the laugh to get with a Kelly
Clarkson character is someone who would
out Leslie Knope Leslie Knope exactly
you would finally somebody who Leslie
Knope would be like she's too much not
the first time I've heard that probably
not the last my husband says that every
night and then he says I love you I will
not stop talking until you subscribe to
my youtube channel that's right and I
could talk a lot seriously not gonna
stop yep still here not going anywhere I
see you don't walk away from this